Esta es la pregunta del millón de Euros ¿Por
qué EUROPA no crece? Pensadlo bien: la Unión
Europea es la segunda economía del mundo,
sólo por detrás de Estados Unidos. Sin embargo,
de las 50 empresas más grandes del mundo,
sólo 8 son están en suelo europeo. Mientras
la bolsa de Nueva York está on FIRE, los
mercados de valores europeos están en números
rojos. Y eso incluye la bolsa de Frankfurt,
la de Paris y, por supuesto, la de Madrid.
¿Y qué me decís de los gigantes tecnológicos?
Todos hemos oído hablar de Google, de Apple
o de Amazon pero… ¿Cuál sería su equivalente
en Europa? Por supuesto que hay algo porque
tiene que haber de todo. En Alemania tienen
SAP, que se dedican a las bases de datos…
Los suecos tienen Spotify… pero vamos, que
ninguna de estas empresas le llegan a la suela
de los zapatos a un Facebook o un Uber cualquiera.
Y esto es especialmente problemático si tenemos
en cuenta que la economía mundial está en
pleno auge. Sí, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
si juntamos el PIB de todos los países del
planeta, tanto los ricos como los pobres,
tenemos un crecimiento del 3.1%, que no está
nada mal. Sin embargo, la Unión Europea a
duras penas llega al 2.5%.
Y, creedme, esto no son buenas noticias. Poco
crecimiento implica pocos trabajos y poco
dinero para todos. A fin de cuentas, si cualquier
empresa China o Estadounidense se come el
mercado, es cuestión de tiempo que las empresas
Europeas se hundan ¡Así que buena suerte
buscando un buen sueldo!
Y precisamente por eso, muchos políticos
creen que Europa tiene que apostar por las
grandes empresas. Pues bien, en ese contexto
es donde tuvo lugar esta noticia de principios
de 2019.
La Unión Europea bloquea la fusión de ALSTOM-SIEMENS
debido a las preocupaciones por la competencia
Básicamente, la idea era la siguiente: Alstom
es una empresa francesa que fabrica trenes
de alta velocidad ¿Habéis visto alguna vez
los TGVs franceses? ¿Esos trenes que salían
en Misión Imposible? Pues están fabricados
por ALSTOM. Y Siemens es una empresa alemana
con una división que también fabrica trenes
de alta velocidad. Si se hubieran fusionado,
habrían creado la segunda empresa más grande
del sector de fabricación de trenes ¿Y cuál
es la primera? Pues exacto, una empresa China.
Es decir que, de nuevo, Europa quiere competir
con China en el mundo de la tecnología.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué han prohibido
la fusión? Y aquí es donde llegamos a uno
de los grandes dilemas económicos. La base
del libre mercado es la competencia entre
empresas. Es decir, que si muchas empresas
luchan por conseguir más clientes, terminarán
ofreciendo mejores bienes y servicios… y
a mejor precio. Ahora bien ¿Qué pasa cuando
una empresa se hacen tan grande que se come
a las demás? En este caso, hablamos de un
monopolio. Por ejemplo, imaginad que Alstom
y Siemens se hubieran fusionado. En ese momento,
el Gobierno de España necesita comprar nuevos
trenes para las redes de alta velocidad. Si
sólo hay una única empresa capaz de cumplir
con los requisitos ¿Por qué iban a bajar
el precio? A fin de cuentas ¡Son la única
alternativa! Pueden evitar que nazcan nuevos
negocios y terminar imponiendo sus condiciones.
Es decir, que terminaríamos con lo opuesto
a lo que entendemos por libre mercado.
Por otra parte ¿Hasta qué punto es bueno
que el Estado o, en este caso, la Unión Europea,
se meta a decidir lo que hace una empresa?
Como veis… se trata de un dilema en toda
regla. Y de uno de los grandes debates ideológicos
de nuestro tiempo. No se trata de la clásica
pelea entre liberalismo versus socialismo.
Más bien, podríamos hablar que es una pugna
entre dos visiones distintas del capitalismo:
la francesa y… ¡la alemana! Así que la
pregunta es ¿Ha sido buena idea bloquear
la fusión de Alston Siemens? ¿Qué es eso
de capitalismo francés y capitalismo alemán?
¿De verdad Europa necesita gigantes económicos
para poder crecer? Hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes…
Antes voy a hacer un paréntesis. Veréis,
tengo una amiga que tiene un hijo de 7 años.
Y esta niño de 7 años tiene leucemia. La
leucemia es una de esas enfermedades que te
puede llevar a la tumba y afecta, sobretodo,
a los niños. Si queréis más información,
en este vídeo lo explican fenomenal. El caso
es que la leucemia se puede curar si te hacen
un trasplante de médula ósea ¿El problema?
Que es muy difícil encontrar médula ósea
compatible ¿Por qué? Porque hay muy poquitos
donantes. Y es bastante triste porque todos
tenemos médula de sobra. Es más, estamos
produciéndola continuamente así que dar
un poquito para alguien que la necesita es
gratis. La única razón por la que no lo
hacemos es pereza. Y el primero en entonar
el mea culpa soy yo. En otras palabras, que
no hay ninguna excusa razonable para no salvar
la vida de un niño.
¿Y cómo funciona esto de donar médula?
Pues muy fácil, buscáis en Google “donar
médula ósea en mi país”. Llamáis al
centro de donantes que tengáis más cerca
y pedís una cita. Ahí os harán unas pruebas
y os meterán en un registro internacional.
Si hay alguien, en algún lugar del mundo,
que necesite vuestra médula, os llamarán
para que vayáis a donar. Yo he pedido cita.
Y vosotros… ¡Pues no esperéis más! En
cuanto terminéis este vídeo, abrís una
pestañita en el navegador y pedís una cita
¡Que no se diga que en VisualPolitik somos
unos perezosos!
Y ahora sí… vamos a ver un poco de historia.
CAPITALISMO FRANCÉS vs CAPITALISMO ALEMÁN
Los que lleváis tiempo suscritos a VisualPolitik
recordaréis este vídeo en el que hablábamos
de Francia. Francia es la patria de los croissant,
las baguettes y el dirigismo económico. Desde
la época de Charles de Gaulle, el capitalismo
francés funciona como un ejército. Por supuesto
que hay empresas privadas y cierto sentido
de la competencia. Pero, durante décadas,
la filosofía económica en Francia es que
el Estado tiene que proteger y ayudar a sus
grandes empresas. Montar una empresa nueva
en este país puede ser un dolor de cabeza.
Ahora bien, una vez eres grande, el Estado
te pone la alfombra roja.
Es más ¿Recordáis que os decía que, de
las 50 empresas más grandes del mundo, sólo
8 son europeas? Pues bien, de esas 8 empresas,
3 son francesas. Y esto no es casualidad.
El capitalismo alemán es todo lo contrario.
Por supuesto que en Alemania hay regulaciones
y tienen impuestos. Pero, en este caso, las
leyes económicas están pensadas para proteger
un bien superior: el medio ambiente, los derechos
laborales, o la competencia…
¿Queréis un ejemplo? Os doy un ejemplo,
la política energética. Si recordáis, en
otro vídeo os contábamos que Alemania está
totalmente en contra de la energía nuclear
por razones ecológicas. Eso significa, entre
otras cosas, que producir electricidad en
este país es bastante caro. Sin embargo,
Francia es el país nuclear por antonomasia.
Ningún otro país tiene tantas centrales
nucleares. Eso significa que, en principio,
Francia podría producir energía más barata
¿Verdad? Pues nada de eso. Si entráis en
expatistan.com podéis ver que la factura
de la luz en Munich es prácticamente idéntica
a la de Paris ¿Y esto por qué ocurre? Pues…
por razones como esta.
Un grupo de defensa de consumidores franceses
dice que el monopolio de EDF está subiendo
los precios
Exacto, para que os hagáis una idea, en Alemania
hay un montón de empresas energéticas. Y
ninguna tiene participación del Estado. Hay
una pequeña excepción, que sería E.ON,
pero que sólo tiene un 2% de accionariado
en manos de un gobierno regional. El resto
son completamente privadas. Y compiten al
mismo nivel. Sin embargo, en Francia hay un
gran gigante: EDF. Y el 70% del accionariado
de EDF está en manos del Gobierno Francés.
Esto significa un apoyo enorme y unas condiciones
de casi monopolio.
Por supuesto que no todo es malo. Gracias
al apoyo público, EDF es la 3ª empresa energética
más grande del mundo. De hecho, están presentes
en muchísimos países, tanto en Europa como
en África. El precio lo pagan los consumidores
franceses.
Y lo mismo pasa con otros sectores. Por ejemplo,
los automóviles. Francia tiene dos grandes
gigantes del sector: Renault y el grupo Peaugeot-Citroen,
que están fusionados. Muchos podríais pensar
que son empresas privadas, que compiten en
el mercado libre como cualquier otra ¿verdad?
Pues… ¡Nada más lejos de la realidad!
En ambos casos, el gobierno de Francia es
uno de los principales accionistas. En el
caso de Renault, el estado francés tiene
el 15% del capital. Todo esto significa un
colchón económico enorme que viene directamente
de los impuestos de todos los franceses. Gracias
a este apoyo, Renault tiene una posición
de partida mucho más cómoda que muchas otras
marcas de coches ¡Pero no sólo eso! Al tener
tantas acciones, el Estado puede intervenir
directamente en las decisiones de la empresa.
Por ejemplo, París nunca permitiría que
Renault terminara en manos extranjeras. Y
muchas veces, el estado ha vetado el cierre
de fábricas o incluso han dado subvenciones
para desarrollar nuevos modelos de coches.
¿Y qué pasa en Alemania? Pues, en este caso,
el Gobierno alemán no tiene acciones de ninguna
empresa de coches. BMW, por ejemplo, es totalmente
privada. Volkswagen está participada por
un ayuntamiento pero es totalmente independiente
del estado. Es decir, que Alemania no ayuda
ni deja de ayudar a sus empresas. Y algo parecido
ocurre en los países nórdicos. Y eso explica
noticias como esta.
Geely Holdings completa la adquisición de
las acciones de AB Volvo
En este caso hablamos de un grupo Chino comprando
una de las empresas más grandes de toda Suecia.
El Gobierno Sueco no dijo ni esta boca es
mía. Todo esto sería impensable en Francia.
No sólo es que haya un sinfín de regulaciones
contra la inversión extranjera. Es que, además,
el estado sería accionista y bloquearía
cualquier adquisición. Pero, sin duda alguna,
donde mejor se ve esta diferencia de mentalidad
es en la historia que os vamos a contar ahora
mismo.
EL GIGANTE SOBRE RAÍLES
Esto tan bonito que está sonando es la música
de HARDBONE, un grupo alemán de rock duro
que nos ha enviado su música.
Concretamente, este tema que escucháis se
llama “No man´s land”, “En tierra de
nadie”. Y es que hubo un momento donde China
era una “tierra de nadie” para las empresas.
El país crecía como la espuma, necesitaban
carreteras, puentes y trenes pero no tenían
empresas propias que las pudieran construir.
Así que en 2004, Siemens consiguió un acuerdo
millonario para construir trenes de alta velocidad
en China ¿El problema? Pues que los Chinos
negocian como nadie. Una de las condiciones
que pusieron es que, por cada ingeniero alemán
que estuviera en el proyecto, tenía que haber
uno Chino ¿Conclusión? Los chinos aprendieron
en seguida cómo fabricar trenes. Años más
tarde, Siemens terminó el contrato y China
ya tenía lo que quiería: tecnología. Con
esa tecnología crearon su propia empresa
de fabricación de trenes: CRRC. Y no hablamos
de una empresa cualquiera. Hablamos de un
auténtico gigante de proporciones nachovidalianas…
CRRC, el gigante sobre raíles chino al que
Europa tiene miedo.
La corporación generó unos ingresos de 26.000
millones de euros en 2017
Pues, exactamente, en el mundo de las empresas,
el tamaño importa. Con todo ese dinero, CRRC
es la empresa más grande del sector, puede
hacer inversiones enormes y comerse a los
competidores. Ya han conseguido contratos
en Estados Unidos, Serbia y República Checa.
Así que… ¿Qué piensa un francés cuando
quiere hacer frente a un competidor extranjero?
Pues… esto.
La Alemana Siemens y la Francesa Alstom se
fusionarán para crear un nuevo campeón ferroviario
europeo
Para que os hagáis una idea, esta empresa
iba a ser la segunda más grande del sector
a nivel mundial. Y os preguntaréis ¿Dónde
iban a tener su sede? Pues exacto… ¡En
París! Así que todos estaban contentos:
los accionistas, el gobierno de Francia y
el gobierno de Alemania ¿El problema? El
problema son las leyes antimonopolio.
Básicamente, si dos empresas grandes se fusionan,
necesitan una autorización especial. En Europa,
en límite para determinar qué es grande
y qué no lo es son 5000 millones de euros
de facturación y 250 millones de euros dentro
de Europa. Si la empresa que surge de esa
fusión rebasa esos límites, tiene que pedir
permiso a la Comisión Europea. Y ahí es
cuando nuestros amigos de Alstom Siemens se
toparon con la señora Marguerite Vestager.
Vestager dice “NO” a la megafusión Siemens-Alstom
Vestager es la comisaria de competencia. Algo
así como la ministra del gobierno de Europa
encargada de regular a las grandes empresas.
Aunque sea una política danesa, podríamos
decir que Vestager es la principal representante
del capitalismo alemán. Su argumento es que
Alstom-Siemens sería lo suficientemente grande
como para barrer al resto de pequeñas empresas
de trenes. Pensar que, además, hablamos de
un sector muy conectado a los estados. Casi
todos los trenes que se construyen en Europa
están pagados por los gobiernos. Así que
imaginad quién ganaría todos los concursos
públicos tanto en Francia como Alemania.
Y aquí es donde llega el gran dilema.
El ministro de economía francés, Brune LeMaire,
ha defendido vívidamente la fusión de Alstom
y Siemens “La Unión Europea estaría cometiendo
un enorme error político y económico si
rechaza la fusión”.
Como os podéis imaginar, tanto el gobierno
de Francia como el de Alemania han hecho toda
la presión posible para que saliera la fusión.
Su argumento era que, sin Alston-Siemens,
los Chinos terminarían fabricando todos los
trenes europeos. El argumento de Vestager
era que la mejor forma de hacer frente a China
es con innovación y que para eso, es mejor
tener muchas empresas compitiendo.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Quién tiene razón? ¿Qué habríais hecho
vosotros? ¿Habríais aceptado la fusión
Alstom-Siemens? ¿Creéis que Europa necesita
ayudar a sus empresas para que se conviertan
en gigantes económicos? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios. Y como siempre,
no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas, así que suscribíos a VisualPolitik
y dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones.
Eh! Y ahora que ha terminado el vídeo, ya
no tenéis excusa. Todos a buscar a pedir
cita para registraros para donar médula…
ósea. No esperéis más ¿O acaso vais a
dejar de salvar una vida sólo por pereza?
Abrid la pestañita en el navegador ahora
mismo y pedid una cita en vuestro centro de
donación más próximo!